una compañía produce procesadores para
teléfonos celulares en una de sus
fábricas más grandes el 2% de los
procesadores que se producen presentan
algún defecto en una inspección de
control de calidad se seleccionan y se
prueban aleatoriamente 500 procesadores
cuál es la media y la desviación
estándar del número de procesadores
defectuosos en esta muestra como siempre
pausa el vídeo e inténtalo por tu cuenta
después lo trabajaremos juntos ok
déjame definir una nueva variable
aleatoria a la cual le podamos calcular
la media y la desviación estándar de
hecho voy a definirla como la variable
aleatoria del número de procesadores
defectuosos en esta muestra así que
déjame anotarlo voy a decir que la
variable aleatoria x
va a ser igual al número de procesadores
defectuosos en esta muestra
el número de procesadores defectuosos en
una muestra de 500 procesadores y la
primera cosa que puedes reconocer es que
esta es una variable binomial déjame
anotarlo esta de aquí es una variable
binomial
cómo podemos saber que es binomial bueno
la inspección consta de 500 ejecuciones
por lo tanto tiene un número finito de
ejecuciones la probabilidad de obtener
un procesador defectuoso es siempre la
misma que puedes ver como la
probabilidad de éxito es un poco contra
intuitivo que obtener un procesador
defectuoso sea un éxito pero lo que
estamos buscando la probabilidad de
obtener un procesador defectuoso
entonces podemos decir que la
probabilidad de obtener un procesador
defectuoso es constante a lo largo de
estas 500 ejecuciones y bueno podemos
suponer que son independientes una de la
otra y que esta probabilidad es del 2%
es decir del 0.02
ok tal vez me puedas decir hey hay
reemplazo o no hay reemplazo pero
suponiendo que tenemos esta muestra de
una población funcional infinita de
procesadores esto realmente no importa
pero si te hace sentir más cómodo
reemplazar los procesadores que tomamos
aunque no lo digan
puedes pensarlo de esa manera así que
suponiendo que estas ejecuciones son
independientes y que la probabilidad de
obtener un procesador defectuoso es
constante podemos concluir que tenemos
una variable binomial aleatoria
y ya sabemos las fórmulas para la media
y la desviación estándar de una variable
binomial aleatoria voy a decir que la
media de x o dicho de otra manera el
valor esperado de esta variable binomial
aleatoria x es igual y bueno ya vimos al
número de ejecuciones que a eso le
habíamos puesto el nombre de n por la
probabilidad de éxito en cada una de
esas ejecuciones por b así que en este
caso en especial voy a obtener que el
valor esperado de x va a ser igual a 500
ejecuciones voy a tomarme 500
procesadores ok ya esto multiplicarlo
por la probabilidad de éxito que es la
probabilidad de obtener un procesador
defectuoso que eran de 0.02
ahora tengo 500 x 0.02 500 por dos
centésimas bueno eso es lo mismo que 10
por lo tanto puedo concluir que el valor
esperado o la media de la cantidad de
procesadores defectuosos que encontrarás
en el control de calidad es de 10 ok y
ahora como encontramos la desviación
estándar bueno la desviación estándar de
esta variable aleatoria x es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de la varianza de esta
variable aleatoria x bueno esta es una
forma en la que la puedes encontrar con
la otra anotación que puedes encontrar
es la siguiente esto es igual a la
varianza de x
déjame ponerlo también así la anotación
a veces es la parte más confusa de la
estadística y bueno esto es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de y tengo la cantidad de
datos que ya habíamos dicho que es n por
la probabilidad de éxito que ya habíamos
dicho que era p por 1 - esta
probabilidad de éxito por 1 - p
ok todo esto está adentro del radical
ok así que en este ejercicio esto es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de bueno tengo
n que sabemos que son 500 procesadores
500 que va a multiplicar a la
probabilidad de éxito que como ya vimos
es 0.02 y esto a su vez va a multiplicar
a 1 - pm 1 - esta probabilidad bueno eso
es lo mismo que 0.98 ok entonces todo
esto está adentro de nuestro radical y
esto va a ser igual a bueno esto es lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de m
y ya habíamos dicho que quinientos por
dos centésimas eran 10 10 x 0.98 es 9.8
y ahora la raíz cuadrada de 9.8 mes y
usamos la calculadora déjame traerla por
acá y voy a sacar la raíz cuadrada de
9.8 ok su raíz cuadrada es esto y
obtengo 3.3 cm si redondeamos a la
centésima más cercana así que déjame
ponerlo esto de aquí va a ser
aproximadamente igual a 3.13 si
redondeamos a la centésima más cercana
esta es mi desviación estándar y si
quiero la varianza sería de 9.8 en fin
espero que hayas disfrutado este
problema nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo